but still money and important points to
play for for these two players and here
we go here we go it's blitz five minutes
on the clock now per player and it's the
same oh until this last move it was the
same opening as the previous game which
did end in a draw and uh this time no
open spanish as we call it it's a very
closed position with all the pieces
still on the board we uh now due to
jordan's last move we
arrive in a position that's gonna become
about maneuvering potentially black the
first to castle white will do the same
shortly and uh you're happy to see this
opening
uh yeah in some respects i am i mean uh
again it's it's a long maneuvering very
subtle game and i think the interesting
thing is well if liam wins this game is
he going to be a bit annoyed because he
could have played this in the in the
game to win the whole tournament maybe
he shouldn't win this game uh but it's
yeah it's always fascinating to see how
these top players uh place their pieces
in this maneuvering battle
yeah and actually i think it was jordan
who made the first change from that last
game so um so yeah liam
i mean i just wonder how he's feeling in
general just by taking space there
covering some squares but how will you
feel if you know you were so close from
the biggest tournament victory of your
life so much money such big prize at
stake yeah it's hard to refocus now on
just a blitz game but i have to say liam
actually has done that remarkably um
well because he also did it against
young christoph duda
so many times you know in their match he
was winning and he failed to win in fact
even lost at some point but then when it
came to tie breaks
he managed to kind of kick into gear i
think he's one of the coolest customers
liam lee i mean when he's in these
situations you can just tell he's just
very relaxed you know he plays good
moves he plays them quick i mean look at
him there you can you can see there's
not really any stress on his face and
he's had a great tournament anyway so
enjoy this last couple of games we have
to remember he is a full-time he has a
full-time job working for the university
as a chess coach it's quite impressive
to perform at this level yeah
when you also work and he's not just a
chess coach coach as well you know he's
also director of the website chess team
so that means that you know he's looking
for recruitment he's planning out
exactly what they're going to do so it's
not just like let me rock up and let me
train with some of the finest young
minds
there's a lot of admin work as well yeah
yeah and uh i mean the reason he's so
good at these playoffs is
he's a blitz specialist he's the former
world blitz champion i think in what was
it 2012 2013 he won the world blitz
championship and
uh yeah we've seen him in the playoffs
be super fast the reason he nearly won
this tournament is because he even beat
duda in a in a playoff in a tie break
like this one and okay maneuvering stage
is just finished just as we uh come in
now we see a set of trades of pawns in
the center things are starting to open
up and black just shuffling the rook
in the middle it's very very tense one
slit from either side and the advantage
could swing
first it's still about improving pieces
black has an isolated pawn in the middle
of the board but he's trying to trade it
off now trying to trade it off for
white's very strong central pawn still
barely pause from liam yeah i think both
players are in their preparation as they
should be in quite a well-known uh line
not that i know that i'm assuming it is
and
here the only danger is that too many
pieces pawns will get exchanged off but
the thing is it's really opening up and
that generally leads to a very exciting
game with the pieces still on the board
and can white get the knight to that
square we love so much uh a knight on f5
will thrive and uh caillou you were
asking about this earlier actually that
night getting to that square and uh we
we could see it come towards the black
king um i always remember from these
kind of openings the famous kasparov
karpov matches and there was uh some
great victories uh by both players in
those really impressive world
championship matches uh which mean
ivanka at least uh were brought up to
really weren't we you know um and it's
great you know great to have those
memories neither of these players were
alive at the time but i'm sure they
could hang on to those games just don't
rub it
yeah i know i'm old but you know
it wasn't even
sorry david wasn't even oh no i just met
such a youngster you're such a youngster
i just met these players they're very
classically educated they would have
studied those
slightly older games
but look at the clock time suddenly
jordan he's frozen he's gone into the
tank he's spent a minute and a half now
on this one move and it's very
complicated it's very tense firstly that
shows he's not actually in his
preparation anymore he's on his own uh
he's got to look at this position with
fresh eyes but also he's stuck for moves
okay bringing out his bishop very
logical but temporary pawn sacrifice
suddenly black is one of pawn in the
middle of the board how is jordan going
to justify that
find compensation for that pawn he's
given up i guess uh now it's uh simon's
idea coming into play you know perhaps
putting a knight onto the beautiful f5
square yeah i don't necessarily think it
should be done now sure
but it will be
there
yeah i mean uh you can see white's
pieces are looking quite good maybe you
can just move the light square bishop
one square as well just line it up
against the king get it back on that
diagonal but it is a porn sacrifice uh
to me it looks like i don't know i was i
was just going to suggest this actually
but then i thought no
will never happen but uh yeah okay so we
did see a temporary sacrifice from white
and a whole flurry of tactics there we
don't have time to show it but the
queens have come off a set of rooks have
come off and actually it's just level
trades apart from black maintaining his
extra pawn the key reason for jordan
going for this is white has got the
bishop pair white has the two bishops in
return black has more knights so still
roughly level material it's just about
whether the bishops now compensate for
black sex report and the winner of the
tournament young christopher has tweeted
mommy tu ma boy what's that mean mommy
too i i'm not quite sure so i guess uh
i'll well if our viewers can help us out
and tell us what mummy too perhaps means
um
yeah google translate then uh twitter
using chess champs and i will translate
the message i'm i'm going to bet this
goes to armageddon you think yeah anyone
would have a little cheeky bet against
that no because
because we were having a discussion
earlier at lunch
i've tried google translated okay it
means we got it
ah okay we got it got it yes you got it
young christophe duda the winner of the
tournament these two are fighting for
important prize money so the winner and
tie breaks gets five thousand dollars
the loser in tie breaks get two thousand
five hundred dollars and prize money is
what matters when it comes to the
overall tour standings by the end of the
season we will name a overall tour
winner the best online rapid player in
the world
and it is important then to gain as much
prize money as possible yeah and dude
after this result must be doing great in
the tour standings overall also a
previous finalist in one of the other
events okay meanwhile black's knight
jumping into the center and white's rook
coming out of the eyeline of that black
knight
you might be right simon this game might
fizzle out towards the drawer black does
have this extra pawn but more exchanges
are inevitable
and okay black's knights dancing into
the middle of the board will we see
white's rook step up one square capture
that black pawn in the middle
that looks very healthy to me but it
also looks like it might lead to a
forced draw
so liam with two extra minutes on the
clock he's saying to jordan okay let's
just trade everything off the board
rooks have now left now this black
knight attacking white's light square
bishop also blacks like square bishop
attacking the white knight in the center
dead draw dead draw yeah i predict that
uh jordan is going to offer trade of
knights oh no he didn't
he may be playing for the win still
maybe but
risky
there's opposite color bishops as well
it's very difficult for
the night and bishop to actually target
a weak point black knight i'm expecting
to dance back now
it's done its job in the center of the
board there we go actually a huge threat
in the position the black knight wants
to jump down to the e2 square and check
the white king attack the white bishop
at the same time either of those pieces
needs to move the white bishop or king
needs to move right now to safe squares
that black knight is just too strong too
dangerous yeah maybe you can yeah the
bishop does move in the end so just uh
but what happens if you take pawn here
then it says something i guess you also
take the pawn
oh yeah
yeah or white can do the same thing that
black just did retreat the white knight
maybe um okay the black knight under
fire will we see it grab a pawn but
plant itself on an odd square the pawn
in front of the white king is up for
grabs by that black knight and
maybe you can get away with it if liam
wants to win he will capture that white
pawn on the g2 square
no he doesn't he retreats repeats the
position hey this is the second time
we've seen this position now if the
position repeats for a third time
i predict draw incoming
[Laughter]
liam has the advantage of white in the
next round as well so i mean if i was
him i'd save the energy and go go on to
having the white pieces so i mean i mean
you can't win this position this level
really surely almost completely uh
symmetrical the pawn structure and the
opposite color bishops they kind of
they're like ships passing each other in
the night balancing each other out the
knights will cancel each other out as
well
level material no imbalance at all this
is about as drawish as it comes yeah
yeah
i mean even if one side wins the pawn
it's probably still a draw um and that's
the best you can hope for in in a blue
moon um maybe liam decided not to repeat
the position because look at the clock
times black does have two extra minutes
on the clock maybe that'll be a factor
maybe jordan will get nervous if he gets
under one minute
the players only gain three seconds
after every move so will he take the
knights now if he takes the knights they
can they can wrap up and get ready for
the next game um but if he doesn't
capture the night he's still
trying something moment of truth will
black trade the knights will liam go for
the draw
he didn't previously he could play on
here maybe he's calculating whether he
can jump into the center with his king
now the black knight will fall but if
the black knight is captured the white
bishop falls as well so no trade jordan
stepping back
still the same dilemma nitrate or no
night trade liam will he play for the
win well there's a pattern here liam
absolutely wants to
squeeze out this position for as long as
possible keeps the knights on the board
yeah liam is definitely the one trying
to press look at the black king it's
more active than its counterpart white's
king is okay in the center but black's
king is going towards that white pawn on
the beast on the b file and i have to
say we have seen jordan uh lose maybe a
couple of positions he should have drawn
um in in you know in endings especially
yesterday when he's playing mamajara for
maybe liam is well aware of that and
just keeping a bit of pressure on but
it's the king isn't it the king is so
active why not play that is a good move
though yeah but you know it's allowing
black to kind of go for the b pawn
yeah suddenly look at the evaluation
part it's gone up in black's favor okay
liam repeats the position first this is
the second time we've seen this position
but he's going to play for the win he's
going to either put the black knight on
a different square or he's going to go
back where it came from and okay this is
the square i was expecting uh as ivanka
says at some point liam will make a dart
with the black king or black knight for
that white pawn on the b2 square which
is very lonely it must be said
okay advancing now from jordan
still difficult to make progress black's
pawn on that left side weak as well and
okay locking up the position
yeah i wasn't a fan of that one i
actually thought that you could wait a
little bit more um but okay giving a
check liam still very much better it's
his pieces that are the ones that are
putting white's forces under pressure
say i'm very worried for jordan suddenly
the momentum has changed black's bishop
can join the fun look how the black
bishops lined itself up with the white
king and with the white knight if the
black king moves now to the center one
square black will win this is a good
move i mean i think he has to go a
little bit passive here to control the
squares the black king can come into and
get out of a possible pin uh as well uh
i mean it instead of draw but he's
making it as hard as possible to to get
the draw just for the activity of the
the pieces look at black's pieces look
at white's pieces look at that white
knight completely locked in that white
knight is totally utterly dominated by
the black bishop nights on the rim are
dim nights on the
yeah and what about this nice on the
bottom of the board i don't know they're
on the edge just on the rim
nights on the first are the worst ah
david did you just think of that yeah
you're so sharp
let's go all the way to armageddon david
is ready that was impressive
meanwhile white is trying to distract
the black army by pushing pawns trying
to trade off as many pawns as possible
that might bring safety but that white
knight it could just be out of the game
and it's completely locked in now
instead of porn trades
it's so hard to win this position still
because everything's disappearing but
he's doing a great job of trying the
time disadvantage though that uh jordan
had he's now up on the clock and uh he's
insisting on all the trades the problem
is if you trade the black knight for the
white bishop right now black's king
can't creep into the position still no
way through
before the paws disappear dead draw yeah
may i mean i was thinking this is maybe
the last ditch attempt but
i do think that can be easily handled
maybe by pushing the pawn forward
swapping more yep everything off
yeah forcing another final trade on the
right half the right half of the board's
been completely obliterated
and uh yeah the vacuum cleaner is out
everything's just getting hooked off the
board now
liam will have the white pieces and
blitz game number two
actually he could have forced the draw
immediately actually by
capturing the knight yeah and then uh
sacrificing his knight there we go here
it is
the first one is a draw between jordan
and liam you another white pieces in
this one and in five minutes blitz game
number two